rund fünf milliarden menschen leben in
staaten mit bewaffneten konflikten in
dieser welt der gewalt sei philosophie
unverzichtbar sagt der philosoph charles
fränkl
er glaubt an den praktischen nutzen
seines fachs und bereits die 5
konfliktzonen und bei studenten und
laien die philosophische debatten kultur
zu fördern
mit brain gegen bomben herr frenkel
genau das ist so ein bisschen die idee
dass man also argumente austauschten
statt kugeln und was war eigentlich ihre
persönliche motivation als relativ
junger erfolgreicher
philosophieprofessor die uni zu
verlassen und in israel über
stacheldraht zeichnen zu steigen um fast
im untergrund workshops philosophische
abzuhalten
ja also die grundidee des projektes
tatsächlich dass man die philosophie so
ein bisschen raus und damit aus dem
akademischen elfenbeinturm und ich will
eben zeigen dass die philosophie
durchaus auch nützlich sein kann für
menschen die in der realen welt leben
und die sich mit fragen und
herausforderungen auseinandersetzen die
nichtsdestotrotz philosophisch
interessant sind und und ich muss sagen
das hat sich eigentlich bewahrheitet
also ich hab die fünf philosophie
workshops in verschiedenen konfliktzonen
der welt organisiert und das hat
eigentlich immer gut geklappt also die
leute haben verstanden worum es ging und
wir haben dann wirklich viele
interessante fragen besprechen können wo
waren sie das ganze hat angefangen 2006
an einer palästinensischen universität
in ost jerusalem
da habe ich hatte den ersten workshop
abgehalten mit palästinensischen
studenten dann war ich an einer
staatlich islamischen universität in
indonesien im jahr darauf
das ist also eine vom staat getragen
islamische universität das war ein
macher star das ist die hauptstädter
problem zu lösen
dann habe ich ein workshop gemacht mit
vom glauben abgefallenen rassischen
juden in new york city
das war wirklich sehr spannend die
lieben wirklich ein doppelleben sie tun
so als ob sie weiterhin ganz streng
religiös orthodox sind aber innen sind
sie sozusagen komplette freidenker die
sich vom judentum als glauben
verabschiedet haben und das land
allerdings nicht in einer universität
wenn ich in einer universität genau das
war also so richtig so eine art secret
workshops wir haben uns eben getroffen
die wollten natürlich nicht dass das
bekannt wird denn sonst hätte das
natürlich ein skandal ergeben in ihrer
in ihrer gemeinde und wir haben uns dann
an verschiedenen orten in einer bar
getroffen und auch in einem privathaus
aber das war so hart geheim unternehmen
der vierte workshop darf anstatt in
brasilien da war ich in salvador dabei
ihr das ist im nordosten brasiliens und
das ist auch das zentrum der afro
brasilianischen kultur kann man sagen
also früher weiter der sklavenmarkt und
der sehr viele zogen die vier millionen
sklaven von afrika nach brasilien
geschickt worden
und da bin ich in die schulen gegangen
denn also in brasilien gibt es seit 2008
ein gesetz das den philosophie
unterricht an schulen obligatorisch
macht also jeder brasilianische
oberstufenschüler muss drei jahre lang
philosophie studieren ob er will oder
nicht
und ich werde in 2010 da und wollte mal
sehen wie das jetzt im klassenraum
eigentlich aussieht wie das funktioniert
was vor allem schüler in armen schulen
in öffentlichen schulen mit der
philosophie machen
und der letzte workshop fand statt
sozusagen zuhause in kanada also da wo
ich jetzt seit 2000 liebe da bin ich zu
einer buch first nation also kanadische
nordamerikanischen ureinwohner oder
indianer genau gegangen
an der grenze zwischen kanada und den
usa und die sind damit befasst also die
wollen sozusagen politisch wieder selbst
bestimmt werden die wollen nationale
souveränität wollen eine eigene nation
wieder sein neben kanada und den usa und
kämpfen also darum und das wird eben
auch ganz spannende fragen auf mich war
so wer soll denn regieren wer gehört zur
gemeinde wer gehört nicht zur gemeinde
wie kann man die traditionelle kultur in
die moderne welt einbauen der sie jetzt
leben also diese art von fragen sind da
grundfragen der politischen philosophie
kann man sagt ja ihr eigentliches heim
gebiet fachgebiet universitäre
spezifikation ist islamische und
jüdische philosophie des mittelalters
das ist schon interessant für mich kann
das bei den ersten drei stationen
nachvollziehen das ist sie dahin zieht
in den in den orient gewissermaßen aber
das ist sie in
in nordamerika dann mitmachen der
handlung das heißt es muss doch etwas
verbindendes geben also bevor wir über
die grenzen und und die differenzen
sprechen was ist das gebieten der all
diese kulturellen identitäten ja also
ich habe eigentlich die orte bewusst
ausgewählt
also ich wollte sozusagen in
konfliktzonen gehen wo die leute
trächtig mit realen herausforderungen
umgehen müssen mit realen fragen umgehen
müssen und diese konfliktzonen sind
natürlich ganz unterschiedlich also
einige sind klar in israel und palästina
islam und der westen aber bei den
russischen juden zum beispiel hat man
dann auch so was wie frömmigkeit
strenggläubigkeit und modernität in new
york in brasilien natürlich rassische
und ökonomische gegensätze und bei den
european die andern hat mich eigentlich
am meisten der umgang mit dem erbe des
kolonialismus interessiert denn der hat
wirklich ganz tiefe wunden hinterlassen
und das ist also ganz schwierig für die
diese wunden mit diesen hunden umzugehen
und also das wird ganz spannende fragen
auf und die idee war einfach zu zeigen
dass die philosophie einem sozusagen
mittel an die hand gibt werkzeuge an die
hand gibt um mit den fragen und
herausforderungen die in diesen
konflikten aufbrechen umzugehen dass man
also zunächst einmal diese fragen
präzise artikuliert aber dann auch
durchaus antworten auf sie ausprobiert
also ist es nicht so dass ich die
philosophie sozusagen als ja so als
weisheit betrachte die antworten selbst
liefert sondern dass ich die philosophie
ganz bescheiden als ein werkzeugkasten
sie mit dem man die fragen die schon da
sind klarer formulieren kann und dann
selbst auch antworten ausprobieren kann
und darum ging es mir eigentlich also zu
zeigen dass die philosophie in diesem
sinne sinnvoll sein kann außerhalb des
aev schule genau ungenau wenn man jetzt
ein bisschen auf ihre motivation zu
sprechen kommen muss natürlich um zu
fragen wieso in aller welt gelernt
in diese zonen dann könnte man ein
bisschen küchenpsychologie oder
philosophisch vielleicht sagen sie sind
ja selbst in ihrer identität jemand der
diese überbrückungs leistung permanent
leisten muss sie haben
jüdischen familiären hintergrund sie
sind in deutschland brasilien
aufgewachsen
sie haben in amerika gelehrt in
deutschland sind jetzt in montreal zu
hause mit ihren kindern ihrer familie
also ich habe auch gelesen sie seien so
etwas wie ein selben mann melting pot
die revolvermänner und ja dann hat man
eine nutzt das war nicht wirklich
schönen ausdruck ja ja da haben sie
recht
also wenn ich sozusagen in meine
biographie zurück gucke dann ist glaube
ich vielleicht der der interessanteste
anknüpfungspunkt für dieses
philosophische projekt so eine art
doppelte identitätskrise sind zwischen
zehn und zwölf soll es als junger
teenager
also ich bin in deutschland geboren und
habe auch meine kindheit in deutschland
verbracht
aber meine eltern kamen aus brasilien
also sind als politische flüchtlinge vor
der brasilianischen militärdiktatur in
den 60er jahren nach deutschland
gekommen und haben uns aber also mich
und meine geschwister bewusst sehr
deutsch aufwachsen lassen weil sie nicht
wollten dass wir uns unwohl fühlen dass
wir irgendwie auffallen und so und 1979
hat brasilien dann eine amnestie für
politische flüchtlinge erlassen da haben
meine eltern dann schieben sie wollten
zurück in ihre heimat kehren und es
stellte sich dann heraus dass für sie
heimat war für mich eigentlich ein exil
an nahrung weise das war wirklich sehr
sehr freuen das war ein echter
kulturschock für mich obwohl ich die
sprache perfekt beherrscht und ein
gewisser weise der brasilianer bin so
vom hintergrund sei irgend ein bisschen
naja ich war also wirklich in
deutschland sozialisiert und das hat
eine ganz eigenartige reaktion
hervorgerufen also ein bizarrer
deutschen nationalismus ich habe also
alles idealisiert was mit deutschland zu
tun hatte obwohl sie jüdischer herkunft
ja genau und das war eben dass das war
mir gar nicht bewusst und ich habe alle
so herabgesetzt was mit brasilien zu tun
hatte ich habe sogar meine eltern
gezwungen gezwungen oder angeregt alle
zwei wochen ein deutsches restaurant zu
gehen obwohl die nie zu hause deutsch
gegessen hatten
und das ging dann irgendwann meinen
großeltern die eben als juden aus
deutschland vertrieben worden sind auf
die nerven in dieser nationalismus und
die gaben mir dann dieses buch der gelbe
stern dass es eine fotodokumentation des
holocaust und als ich das du
durchblätterte da brach dieses
idealisierte deutschlandbild tatsächlich
zusammen und das hat wirklich
konfusion erzeugt also was ist wahr was
ist falsch an das ist interessant was
ist richtig und das heißt quasi die
krise die existenziell die eigene genau
macht dass sie in krisen orte gehen und
dann als genau moderat philosophischer
moderator diese krisen zu zu überbrücken
genau genauso es gibt also eine gewisse
affinität der konfusen menschen glaube
ich haben ein sehr gutes teilweise haben
sie sich denn ihre werte und vielleicht
müssen sie noch ein bisschen sagen was
sind denn diese eigenen werte haben sich
zu sehen werte während dieser workshops
zwischen 2008 und verändert also das bin
ich immer wieder gefragt worden denn ich
glaube nicht dass ich meine
grundposition verändert habe also ich
würde immer noch sagen ich bin atheist
und säkularer und gewisser weise liberal
würde ich sagen
und das war ich eigentlich auch vor
diesen erfahrungen schon und und die
frage ist dann was sollen denn diese
auseinandersetzung wenn man seine eigene
meinung eigentlich nicht grundsätzlich
verändert aber ich denke dass ich
bereitschaft hat sein genau so genau ich
denke die bereitschaft muss man
tatsächlich haben also das ist eine
grundvoraussetzung und ich denke
konversionen finden auch stadt manchmal
nicht anders man also wirklich
grundüberzeugungen auswechselt dass ein
atheist gläubig wird wenn man der
gläubiger atheist wird aber ich denke
das ist selten ich glaube aber es ist
vorgekommen dass man sie zum islam hat
genau genau richtig
ja weil sie der kontakt mit ihren mit
ihrer jüdischen identität in new york im
hinterzimmer hat sich sie das nicht
geschickt hat manchmal ja doch also das
war das war wirklich interessant das war
für mich in kairo das war 2000 das alte
noch bevor ich sozusagen das buch
projekt als solches angefangen habe und
das war für mich wirklich das erste mal
dass ich mit radikal anders denken
nämlich auseinandergesetzt habe also ich
hab damals drei monate in kairo
verbracht ich wollte mein arabisch
verbessern und habe dann mit ägyptischen
studenten die ihr deutsch verbessern
wollten sprachaustausch gemacht
die wolken touristenführer werden das
war damals noch lukrativ werden ägypten
heute leider nicht mehr und wir haben
uns dann angefreundet und je besser wir
uns kennenlernten umso besorgter wurden
wir doch auch bei unsere ganz
unterschiedlichen lebensweisen und sie
wollte mich eben zum islam bekehren weil
sie nicht wollten dass meine seele ewig
in der hölle schmoren ich wollte sie zu
meiner säkularen welt sich bekehren
welchen ich wollte das jetzt wahres
leben für die illusion eines lebens nach
dem tod opfern und das war wirklich
spannend für mich zu sehen wie es aus
freundschaft heraus eigentlich dieses
diese diese besorgnis entstanden ich war
also da
dahinter stand eben nicht irgendwie die
ambitionen den anderen irgendwie zu
verändern sondern aus freundschaft
heraus ging es um das wohl des anderen
und und die haben wir dann ebenso fragen
gestellt
bist du dir sicher dass meine existenz
gottes nicht weiß und kann und ich
musste dann zum ersten mal so viel so
grundüberzeugungen auf denen meine
lebensweise mein weltbild aufbaut
wirklich für diese grundüberzeugung
argumentieren gründe anführen kritisch
darauf reflektieren und das war für mich
extrem spannend obwohl ich diese
grundüberzeugung nicht verändert habe
und ich denke doch dass ich also die
attraktion des anderen weltbildes viel
besser verstehen gelernt habe und haben
diese workshops ganz real an diesen
orten etwas verändert das ist wieder ein
beispiel aus brasilien das mir gut
gefallen hat mehr mit der straßenlaterne
ich weiß nicht drei ja genau her stimmt
er also interessieren da bin ich ja vor
allem eben an die schulen gegangen und
da habe ich diese eine wirklich
charismatische faszinierende lehrerinnen
getroffen augen jeder hebold die also
die leidenschaftlichste philosophin ist
die ich der leidenschaftliche philosoph
den ich in den ich kenne und die hatte
wirklich einen ganz interessanten
pragmatischen ansatz sowie gingen dann
durch die straßen von salvador und sie
zeigte auf straßenlaternen sagte ahadi
funktionieren jetzt wieder dank unseres
philosophie unterricht ist oder löcher
auf der straße waren geschlossen wurden
und dann habe ich sie gefragt also wie
denn die funktionierende straße unter
internem philosophie unterricht zusammen
und dann erzählte sie mir eben
dass sie also den schülern versucht zu
zeigen dass sie durchaus macht haben
also es gibt in brasilianischen städten
gibt es eine rufnummer da kann man
anrufen
sozusagen im rathaus und sich über
probleme beklagen im eigenen service
stelle ja genau und und wenn sich dann
nur einer meldet dann reagiert die stadt
darauf nicht wenn die ganze klasse anruf
dann ist es einer demokratie ebenso dass
die politiker reagieren müssen denn sie
wollen ja nicht große gruppen von frauen
und so haben die stunden die also ihre
schüler eben gelernt wie solche konzepte
wie macht und rechte und so weiter wie
die wie die in der praxis funktionieren
also die hat wirklich versucht die
philosophie in die praxis mit
einzubinden
ich selbst habe eigentlich kein eigenes
programm mitgebracht
kann man sagen das heißt also ich wollte
wirklich die philosophie eigentlich so
als moderatorin benutzen und ich habe
eigentlich immer wieder das feedback
bekommen das also meine gesprächspartner
von diesen gesprächen profitiert haben
dass sie bestimmte fragen was sie
verstehen konnten die gegenseite besser
verstehen konnten dass sie bestimmte
auch problemlösungen besser sehen
konnten aber es ging jetzt nicht direkt
darum sagen wir mal konflikte aufzulösen
oder aber könnte man sagen also dass das
soll ich sagen eine strategie ist ja
auch eine art von zeitgeist entspricht
dass man als akademischer philosoph auch
eine art von rechtfertigungsdruck card
der gesellschaft gegenüber dass das was
man macht ja etwas zurückgibt jahre
gesellschaft dass man dann halt wirklich
dorthin geht wo es bedarf gibt an nach
philosophie brasilien sie haben es
erwähnt gibt es philosophie als
schulfach das ist ja nicht auch nur
unkritisch in brasilien selber wird das
angeschaut was man sagt zwar ist sollten
durch die kinder lesen lernen bevor sie
philosophieren lernen und jajaja sieht
sie so etwas wie ein philosoph sondern
frontera sind dass sie dass sie
rausgehen um mit diesen guten diensten
tatsächlich etwas bewegen können
das real ist ja also ich denke schon und
ich liebe ihn also ganz recht es gibt
einen rechtfertigungsdruck also er hat
denke ich auch ganz konkrete ökonomische
hintergründe
vor allem seit der krise 2008 so die
libro moritz die humanities also unter
diesem rechtfertigungsdruck muss
irgendwie erklären warum steuergelder
darin investiert werden sollen
das war jetzt für mich sozusagen kein
ausschlaggebendes motiv also ich wollte
jetzt nicht irgendwie dem steuerzahler
beweisen dass das was ich mache auch
sinn macht aber ich denke dass das zum
teil auch so rezipiert wird also dass
mir geht es eigentlich darum zu zeigen
dass eben ein akademischer philosoph der
jahrelang in der ausbildung war und sein
wissen verfeinert hat seine techniken
verfeinert hat dass der nicht nur in der
akademischen schwere sozusagen aktiv
sein muss ich denke also ich hab nichts
gegen die akademische philosophie ich
bin nicht jemand der sagt das ist
sinnlos ich betreibe sie selbst ich habe
auch meine eigenen doktoranden und
sofort und so weiter aber ich denke man
kann hin und her geben ich habe also man
kann rausgehen wieder reingehen und man
kann das was man sozusagen innerhalb der
akademie gelernt hat durchaus anwenden
und es ist vielleicht auch das heißt ein
jahr zeitgeist in dem sind das ist eine
generationenfrage ist dass man diese
grenzziehung zwischen elfenbeinturm und
street credibility ein bisschen sehr
flach tritt und sagt es könnte auch so
etwas wie eine graswurzelbewegung sein
dass das was sie machen als in ihrem
buch beschreiben dass sie sagen nimm das
mit einem produkt wenn die welt nach
zehn jahren her
jaja als bewegung angelegen sein könnte
ja ja also auf jeden fall würde ich
sagen dass sie hatten ja vorhin
gefragten warum warum ich diese orte
ausgewählt habe und einen grund war eben
ich denke die haben zum beispiel
charakter nicht wahr also das ist so
relativ breite vielfalt an konfliktzonen
und man kann das dann als modell
benutzen und anderswo hingehen und sowas
ähnliches machen also die idee war eben
nicht alle konflikte der welt zu
erschöpfen sondern sozusagen
beispielhaft aufzuzeigen
eine recht verschiedenen gegenden wie
das funktionieren kann und eben deswegen
auch die recht detaillierten
beschreibung dieser workshops wo ich
sozusagen den lisa dann mitnehmen
sollten allgemein verständlich auch für
eine nicht gebildet also genau deine
umwelt tagen genau genau also man kommt
dann so direkt mit rein in die gespräche
oder zumindest versuche ich das und so
dass man eben sieht ihr sowie das on the
ground in der praxis in der praxis aus
und und wenn das andere aufnehmen und
nachahmen dann bin ich also sehr dafür
könnte man ja auch ein bisschen kritisch
sagen okay eine eine straßenlaterne ist
dabei herausgekommen ist das ein
bisschen vielleicht auch ein bisschen
naiv also wir haben eben große konflikte
große probleme
die welt ist ein tendenziell es raus ja
und wie gehen sie mit diesem eventuellen
vorwurf um zu sagen es ist utopisch oder
das ist naiv
das ist das ist eine sehr gute frage
ich beginne ja das erste kapitel mit der
behauptung dass die philosophie den
nahen osten retten kann und das ist
natürlich rhetorisch überspitzt und ich
behaupte das eigentlich gar nicht in
meinem eigenen namen ich habe dieses
seminar an der al kuds universitäten an
dieser palästinensische universität mit
jemandem gemeinsam gemacht
sari nusseibeh einen palästinensischen
intellektueller philosoph der damals
auch präsident diese universität war und
er hat das mal behauptet und ich bin
dann immer wieder gefragt worden
aufgrund dieser also ich glaube viele
suchen müssen vorsichtig sein mit
rhetorik also aber ich bin aufgrund
dieser behauptung mit der das buch in
gewisser weise anfängt immer wieder
gefragt worden kann denn die philosophie
seiner mal den es den islamischen staat
besiegen kann sie den weltfrieden
schaffen und ich denke man sollte nicht
zu überzogenen erwartungen an die
philosophie haben aber ich denke sie
kann durchaus einen beitrag auch zur
konfliktlösung leisten
denn ich denke oft stehen hinter der
gewalt und hinter diesen konflikten
fragen die philosophisch sehr
interessant sind und die man viele
arbeiten kann wo man also viele
werkzeuge anwenden kann
ich kann ihnen vielleicht ein beispiel
sozusagen aus der jüngsten geschichte
geben daraus darauf gehe ich in dem buch
gar nicht ein
zb die terrorattacke auf charly edu in
paris also muss ich mich nach dieser
zeit war nach derzeit genau da da war
das gutschein erschienen nicht mehr da
sind also muslimische fundamentalisten
die erschießen karikaturisten in paris
die karikaturen des propheten mohammed
veröffentlicht haben oder ein anderes
beispiel christliche fundamentalisten
davon molotow cocktails in kinos die
martin scorseses film die letzte
versuchung christi gezeigt haben ende
der 80er jahre
also das ist natürlich nicht eine
unterart kontroverse fragen zu
bearbeiten
aber dahinter steht durchaus eine ganz
legitime frage und ich war also was hat
vorrang die heiligkeit einer religiösen
tradition die man dann auch respektieren
muss über die man sich nicht lustig
machen darf oder aber eben dieses
unbedingte recht der redefreiheit der
freiheit des künstlerischen ausdrucks
und ich denke das ist eine spannende
frage und ich denke man kann sowohl
gründe für die eine als auch für die
andere position anführen und sich
darüber unterhalten und wenn es einem
gelingt
ich behaupte jetzt nicht dass konflikte
nur durch solche kontroversen fragen
ausgelöst werden aber ich denke die
spielen durchaus eine rolle und wenn es
einem gelingt dieses konfliktpotenzial
das in diesen fragen steckt in eine
produktive diskussion zu verwandeln
dann ist schon einiges gewonnen denn man
kommt aus der diskussion möglicherweise
mit der gleichen meinung wieder raus mit
der man reingegangen ist aber man lernt
doch immer auch die schwächen der
eigenen positionen kennen die stärken
der position des anderen kennen und
deshalb glaube ich dass gewalt in
schärfen dass so etwas benennen was was
wie vielleicht der nächste teil jetzt
sein könnte eine einer solchen arbeit
weil die die texte die sie
auf diese beziehung sich beziehen oder
die philosophen sie sich beziehen eine
textsammlung wäre natürlich wunderbar
gewesen damit man damit man sich auch
vertiefen mit den grundlagen
auseinandersetzen kann weil das ist
scheint ein bisschen der trick zu sein
eine gemeinsame tradition des denkens
den menschen ihren gesprächspartnern
überhaupt vor die augen zu führen
zu sagen es gibt judisch es gibt
islamische es gibt christliche denker
freunde des mittelalters also da wo sie
auch wirklich sehr kompetent sind um
dann seine art von v effekt auszulösen
bei diesen seminaren dass man sagt das
habe ich gar nicht gewusst das war ja
ein guter oder das war ein christ also
das war ja das ist noch von den von den
von den griechen überhaupt übernommen in
die islamische kultur könnten sie uns in
einem kurzen abriss auch noch mal diese
grundlagen des denkens geben dieses
wandern dann denken es ja mit dem sie
ihre gesprächspartner überraschen ja
genau also wir haben in diesen workshops
auch immer wieder eben klassische texte
der philosophie gelesen platon und
aristoteles aber eben dann auch
mittelalterliche philosophen islamische
jüdischer alpha fabia rs monitor sind da
ganz zentralen namen und dann auch
spinosa bis hin zu nietzsche und wir
haben jetzt nicht mit so einem
physiologischen interesse gelesen wir
haben die durchaus gelesen also auch als
sprungbrett in die diskussion und es
ging mir wirklich sehr darum so eine art
kulturimperialismus vorwurf zu vermeiden
also ich wollte wirklich auch an lokale
traditionen des kritischen nachdenken
ist argumentieren dass das ist gutes
diskutierens anknüpfen und habe deswegen
eben philosophen ausgewählt die
sozusagen in diesem tradition in diesen
kulturen verankert waren dh in denen
sich meine gesprächspartner dann auf zum
teil zumindest wiederfinden konnten al
ghazali zum beispiel das eine ganz
zentrale figur
also ein ganz ganz wichtiger islamischer
denker des mittelalters der nach wie vor
als einer der größten islamischen
theologen betrachtet wird wird einen
ganz tollen text geschrieben der mann
wirklich gut als einführung in die
philosophie benutzen kann und auch
plattform eben das buch heißt mit platon
in palästina so planten wurde auch ganz
intensiv in der arabischen welt
rezipiert das heißt also platten gehört
genauso sagt waren etwa also die große
übersetzungs bewegung fand im frühen
mittelalter statt und so vom achten bis
zum 10
jahrhundert sind wirklich die meisten
wichtigen griechischen philosophischen
und wissenschaftlichen texte von platon
bis galin ins arabische übersetzt worden
und sind ein teil einer wirklich sehr
lebendigen sehr reichen intellektuellen
kultur geworden also lange bevor sie
sozusagen im westen wiederentdeckt
wurden
insofern kann man sagen also wie
westliche philosophie beginnt in
griechenland die zweite wichtige epoche
der der der westlichen philosophie ist
eigentlich in der arabischen welt also
die arabische welt gehört auf jeden fall
dazu platten alles gut los und da
zunächst einmal rezipiert und fruchtbar
gemacht worden und dann im späteren
mittelalter ab dem zwölften jahrhundert
leben eben im westen wieder und eines
der großen themen ist quasi die das
verhältnis zwischen philosophie und
religion genau genau also eben ein grund
also ich bin selbst sagen wir mal ich
glaube nicht dass man die denkwelt
dieser mittelalterlichen philosophen
sozusagen als referenzrahmen heute
benutzen kann also ich bin ich sozusagen
kein anhänger von alfa romeo oder moniz
oder möchte jetzt nicht wiederbeleben
aber für meine gesprächspartner die ja
oft aus ebenso streng religiösen
zusammenhängen kam sind die fragen die
diese philosophen bearbeitet haben
wirklich lebendige fragen gewesen ich
war die beziehung zwischen vernunft und
glaube die beziehungs wie geht es also
wie wächst diese islamische philosophie
zu einem zu positionen und ließen diese
positionen wenn sie das kurz also es
gibt da durchaus sie dann eben auch
verschiedene schulen die ist also es ist
kein zusammenhang jenes bild das man da
erhält und diese schulen sind auch im
wettbewerb miteinander
ich habe vorhin alle casali kurz genannt
er hat also elf jetzt 1111 ist er
gestorben und hat gegen ende seines
lebens diese eine intellektuelle
autobiografie geschrieben und dies aus
zwei gründen sehr spannend einmal
beschreibt er so eine glaubenskrise
durch die er gegangen ist als junger
mensch wir sozusagen seinen glauben
verloren hat das zerbrechen des termin
nennt er das und dann beschreibt er wie
er versuchte diesen islamischen glauben
wieder aufzubauen und das hat er getan
indem er die vier haupt interpretation
des islam in seiner zeit sozusagen
untersucht das sind einmal die theologen
die philosophen die mystiker die sophie
mystiker die esoteriker das heißt es
gibt ganz unterschiedliche
interpretationen die zum teil im
widerspruch miteinander stehen und
miteinander konkurrieren
aber und da ist also ein internes
gespräch auch nicht weil die verlosung
reagieren auf die theologen die
theologen reagieren auf die philosophen
etwas für mich sehr spannend ist ist zum
beispiel so sitzungen könnte man sagen
theologische sitzungen die nennen sich
im arabischen kalam das arabische wort
das heißt gespräch oder auch debatte und
da kam also tatsächlich in der
mittelalterlichen islamischen welt dann
vertreter verschiedener religionen in
die islamische welt war religiös
ziemlich vielfältig das heißt es gab den
islam sozusagen als die maßgebliche als
offizielle religion aber dann auch
religiöse minderheiten juden christen
und andere un-vertreter dieser
verschiedenen gemeinden kamen zusammen
und sie mussten sozusagen ihre heilige
schrift an der tür ablegen wie ihn
manche die konnten sie nicht mit rein
nehmen denn das alte testament
oder das neue testament oder der koran
keine keine dieser heiligen schriften
wird von allen teilnehmern des gesprächs
als autorin autoritative sozusagen
anerkannt und insofern muss man dann
wirklich nur mit argumenten für seine
positionen sozusagen ein stehen und kann
also sich nicht auf die autorität der
schrift berufen und das finde ich ist
ein wirklich spannender modell ist sind
das dinge die sie diesen jungen
studenten an den islamischen universität
angesagt haben es gibt diesen genau raum
genau des eigenen gelenken ablegen
thomas und ganz genau also das war für
mich wirklich wichtig denen zu zeigen
dass also ihre eigene religiöse
tradition nicht monolithisch ist also
dass es eben selbst wenn man an seinem
grundverständnis als muslim zum beispiel
oder als jude oder als christ nicht
rütteln lassen will dass es dann doch
durchaus ganz viele verschiedene
interpretationen des islam des judentums
des christentums gibt das heißt man kann
sich sozusagen nicht auf die faule haut
zurück legen sie faule haut in anderen
worten das ja dieser dieser begriff des
taxis das sogenannt tagen auf eine art
von die prägung die man mitbekommen hat
genau genannt dass man die auch
überwindet genau genau genau also ich
denn dieser begriff krieg spiel
tatsächlich dann relativ wichtige rolle
in dem buch und den übernehme ich so ein
bisschen von al ahly den ich ja schon
erwähnt habe und ganz genau dass das ist
damit gemeint ich finde im deutschen
kann man das ganz gut mit diesem begriff
der unmündigkeit auch wieder geben den
erkannt in seiner streitschrift für die
aufklärung benutzt also also ist es
eigentlich alles das was wir nicht
selbst durchdacht haben also als ali
spricht von eltern und lehrern also wenn
wir eben die meinung unserer eltern und
lehrer unkritisch übernehmen man kann
das ausweiten auf medienmarketing
politische religiöse rhetorik also alles
das was uns prägt das unsere meinung
unsere werte prägt das wir aber nicht
selbst durchdacht haben das wenig
kritisch reflektiert haben das
bezeichnete er als taktik und er
beschreibt das eben explizit als einen
nicht wünschenswerten zustand und es war
für ihn keine angenehme erfahrung als
bei ihnen der takt zerbrach so
beschreibt er das
und es wirklich interessant also er sagt
date up lied ist zerbrochen als er
feststellte dass er ein ebenso
leidenschaftlicher jude oder christ
geworden wäre wie er muslim war wenn er
in einer jüdischen oder christlichen
gemeinde aufgewachsen wäre das heißt er
stellt fest dass sein bekenntnis zum
islam eben nicht auf kritische reflexion
beruhte sondern einfach nur durch die
zufälligen umstände seines auftrags und
eine sozialisierung so straße das heißt
wenn man in eine religiöse krise kommt
gewollt oder ungewollt ja wenn man eine
krise überwinden muss weil man konflikte
überwinden muss das heißt dass christen
juden moslems als philosophen
miteinander kommunizieren können wie er
genau genau das ist also auch eine eine
wichtige idee also die krise selbst ist
zunächst einmal vielleicht nicht
angenehm aber aber hat glaube ich auch
etwas befreiendes eben und man ist dann
tatsächlich gezwungen geben sich selbst
gedanken zu machen und man braucht
natürlich dann gewisses werkzeug und
also die philosophen haben das ganz
stark eigentlich in den logischen
schriften des aristoteles gesehene
morgen das ist ja auch so sagen das
werkzeug das des philosophen theologen
hatten sozusagen ihren eigenen
werkzeugkasten aber genau also da ist
dann sozusagen der weg vorbereitet um
sich dann dieses werkzeug anzueignen und
dann damit weiter zu denken wie
reagieren denn die studenten im
arabischen islamischen raum darauf wenn
sie von moni des sprechen einen
jüdischen philosophen ja also mein mund
ist hatte ich eigentlich immer gut
geeignet um sozusagen diese idee einer
doch universell gültigen wahrheit zu
veranschaulichen
zumindest zur diskussion zu stellen der
bund hat also einen berühmten brief an
einen seiner jüdischen schüler
geschrieben
der hatte ihnen gebieten um eine art
biografie also eine liste von
philosophischen werken die sich zu lesen
lohnt
im monat es listet dann eben
verschiedene werke auf und man findet
nicht einen einzigen jüdischen autor
darunter also im viel griechischer
autoren wie aristoteles aber dann auch
viele muslimische autoren das könnte
dann wieder um eine überraschung sein
für die genetischen gläser nicht in der
jüdischen dieser und für die genau für
also für beide seiten ist das eine
überraschung der text muss man sagen in
dem sich dann diese frage ganz gut klar
machen lässt ob die philosophie
möglicherweise tatsächlich eben eine
sprache bereitstellt die es einem
erlaubt über religiöse und kulturelle
abgründe hinweg auch gespräche zu führen
und davon waren defensiven mittelfeld
auf jeden fall überzeugt dass man sind
wir vielleicht nicht so überzeugt aber
es zumindest also also man ist ein guter
einstieg in diesen diese fragestellung
es gibt noch ein wort das ich vorher in
meinem leben noch nie gehört habe eine
bezeichnung befürchte buch gelesen habe
das sind die fall abi listen ja ja das
sind die familie ist ja die
verliererlisten und alphaville ismus ist
so ein bisschen ein philosophisches
kunstwort es bezieht sich auf eine
erkenntnistheoretische positionen aber
was ich damit meine ist eigentlich etwas
ganz einfaches dass man also ja dass man
seine eigenen meinungen und werte nicht
für über jeden zweifel erhaben hält also
dass man zweifel zulässt also auch wenn
man fest überzeugt ist dass man recht
hat und leidenschaftlich dafür
argumentiert für seine für seine meinung
und werte dass man nichts desto trotz
also nicht ausschließt dass man
möglicherweise sich irren kann und dass
der gesprächspartner möglicherweise mit
dem man nicht übereinstimmt recht hat
das ist eigentlich für mich ein fall ist
und ich beziehe das vor allem so auf
diese großen kontroversen fragen gibt es
gott wie es die welt entstanden wie soll
man lieben gibt es ein leben nach dem
tod
worin besteht eine gute politische
ordnung wie sollen männer frauen
behandeln frauen männer wie sollen wir
unsere kinder erziehen also diese diese
kontrolle kontroversen themen ich denke
diesen schwierig die lassen sich nicht
schnell entscheiden wir alle haben
natürlich meinungen dazu
und eben auf starke überzeugung
leidenschaftliche überzeugung aber wenn
man in gespräche mit anders denken gibt
und zugesteht dass man sich
möglicherweise wird dann ist eben ein
produktives gespräch und produktiver
austausch möglich insofern halte ich
diesen fall bilis muss oder das
zugeständnis dass man sich irren kann
halte ich eigentlich für eine wichtige
bedingung für diese gesprächskultur die
ich da oder streit aber wir haben immer
noch das problem eines macht
verhältnisses zwischen mehrheit und
minderheit ja ja das stimmt dass genau
das heißt also viel egoismus ist
sicherlich nicht einmal die einzige
bedingung ich denke es ist dann auch
aufgabe der politik räume zu schaffen
also dass eine minderheit support
integration jaja integration und auch
also dass man eben zum beispiel die
medien denke ich habe da durchaus eine
wichtige aufgabe also dass man jedem
eine stimme gibt
und so auf die verschiedenen stimmen
hört auch wenn sie zu minderheiten
gehören so konkret wie man also sagen
dass dann die sein habe ich mir
eigentlich noch keine gedanken gemacht
aber das also wenn der politische wille
da ist um eine solche diskussionskultur
streitkultur zu fördern dann muss man
sich denke ich da wirklich gedanken
mache ich meine der eine konkrete police
vorschlag geht nicht in dem buch mache
ist eben dass man so ein bisschen wie in
brasilien philosophie unterricht an den
schulen anbietet oder nicht nur anbietet
sondern eben auch tatsächlich
obligatorische macht genau das also
jeder bürger zunächst einmal das
werkzeug mitbekommt um produktive
gespräche zu führen aber ich denke man
muss dann auch über die schule hinaus
denken wie man gesellschaftliche räume
schafft wenn man intellektuelle räume
schafft wo dann dieses gespräch
stattfinden kann und wie man eben
vermeidet dass die mehrheit
also versucht sozusagen also ihre ihre
sichtweise einen anderen hälfte zu
drücken das ist ja gerade in deutschland
jedoch wieder ein großes thema nicht
weil das diese frage einer leitkultur
also da bin ich eigentlich kein großer
fan von ich denke ich denke es ist ich
finde ich schon unglaublich überraschend
dass man also der überraschungseffekt
für mich war dass man sagt die
diskussion um die vereinbarkeit zwischen
glauben und vernunft dass das etwas ist
wo wir ins mittelalter zurück gehen
können um dort lösungsansatz
überlegungen texte zu finden
die damit umgehen und das lässt mein
klischee des mittelalters völlig einmal
weg also dass ich sage wir können also
einer geschichte schöpfen die wir falsch
gelesen haben unsere eigene also dass
das klischee des abergläubischen oder
des dogmatischen mittelalters dass man
sagt es gibt eine art von pluralität
grundsätzlichen denken dass das etwas
ins denken eingebaute ein ding ist weil
ohne ohne eine option der offenheit der
toleranz der bereitschaft des spielraums
gibt es gar keine philosophische anders
erreichung der mentalisten dogmatiker
das nicht können in eine sprachlosigkeit
letztlich sind und dass hier an diesen
pluralismus wieder anknüpfen und zwar
nicht mit einem modernen aktuellen
baukasten sondern mit einem
mittelalterlichen baukasten dass diese
debatten kultur die sie beschreiben
durchaus eben ein 1 1 eine art von
glaubwürdigkeit hat weil sie aus der
tiefe der geschichte kommt ja ja ja ja
das stimmt also das mittelalter ist
weniger mittelalterlich als man als man
denkt also wenn man da so einmal tiefer
einsteigt und sagen wir mal in der
islamischen und jüdischen geschichte
gibt es diesen begriff eigentlich gar
nicht also man denkt eher an ein
goldenes zeitalter und im vergleich zum
team
bis heute eigentlich weniger
intellektuell anregend zugeht
also so ist es durchaus im islamischen
denken verankert das mittelalter und das
endet eben auch nicht also einige dieser
texte die mittelalter geschrieben wurden
die sind dann kommentiert worden bis in
die gegenwart und nach wie vor wichtige
texte interessiert in der traditionellen
ausbildung sagen wir mal in islamisch
theologischen seminaren und ja also man
kann auf jeden fall diese entgegen
setzungen die wir uns so gewöhnt haben
von glaube und vernunft die kann man
wirklich untergraben wenn man ins
mittelalter geht denn da werden glaube
und vernunft eigentlich oft nicht
einander entgegen gesetzt sondern sie
werden auch wirklich oft 1 1 gedacht
diese philosophen im mittelalter mit
denen ich mich auseinander gesetzt habe
einfach aber wer ist mein moment ist bis
zum gewissen grad auch christliche viele
suchen wie thomas kriner die betrachten
eigentlich gott selbst als die vernunft
das heißt die philosophie oder die
praxis der vernunft könnte man sagen ist
eigentlich die höchste form des
gottesdienstes für diese versuchen das
heißt man kann eigentlich sich gott gar
nicht besser ernähren als durch
philosophie und da bricht dann natürlich
diese entgegen setzung von seiner
religion und vernunft religion und
philosophie natürlich dann zusammen denn
das ist also die höchste form der
religiösen praxis ist ja vielleicht auch
schon fast ein dogma sie ja ja auf jeden
fall wenn sie mit jemandem reden der das
nicht akzeptiert ja allgemeine suche
nach der logik nach schlaf vernunft des
guten lebens klar dann ist die
diskussion vorbei klar klar und ich
hatte auch so ein bisschen bedenken
also als ich mit diesem projekt anfängen
also dass ich zum beispiel leute auf so
eine idee ist ische positionen
zurückziehen also dass sie sagen also
vernunft gründe sind ja nett aber ob sie
jetzt für oder gegen meinen glauben
sprechen ist mir egal denn glaube und
vernunft ich haben miteinander nichts zu
tun und es gibt eben diese glaubenslehre
die ist also von der vernunft ganz
unberührt und ja also auch argumente
will ich mich dann gar nicht einlassen
ich habe eben einen glauben und das
reicht mir das ist mir tatsächlich in
der praxis nie begegnet dass sich leute
sozusagen dem gespräch gesperrt habe so
das heißt es
diese offenheit zur interpretation die
gibt es glaube ich wirklich also einer
der wirklich erstaunlich ssten
erfahrungen die ich selbst gemacht habe
und das ist jetzt nicht direkt mit dem
mit dem mit dem mit dem projekt selbst
verbunden
also ich bin in montreal ich lebe in
einem viertel das ist ein bisschen wie
brooklyn
also es gibt tipps das und es gibt
klassische juden sozusagen nebeneinander
und mich hat dann mal ein student also
ein jüdisch orthodoxer student mit zu
einem abendessen sam shepard essen in
einer in einer katholischen familie
genommen und also die frau die schien
nur darauf gewartet zu haben endlich mal
jemanden dazu haben mit dem sie sich
auseinandersetzen konnte also die hatte
ein ganzes arsenal an argumenten für die
traditionelle stellung der frau und für
die traditionelle familienstrukturen
orthodoxen judentum und das hat sie dann
sozusagen wirklich sowieso dann
präsentiert und den ich war den ganzen
abend damit beschäftigt so ein bisschen
für meine liberalen werte also nicht
dazu wären und ich habe so richtig
gemerkt also also die war richtig
schwanger intellektuell schwanger die
die wolke hat jetzt auseinandersetzung
gesucht war dankbar endlich jemand zu
haben der nicht ihre meinung teilte und
da habe ich gemerkt das war so auch so
einer dieser punkte wo ich gemerkt habe
aha also die machen sich ganz viele
gedanken die den ist es nicht unbewusst
dass viele menschen anders denken als
sie die rechtfertigen sich also da ist
ein rechtfertigungsdruck auch und das
war so intellektuell wirklich spannend
für mich also da waren sie seien jagd
intellektueller wetzstein für eine
starke identität
ja genau das hatte natürlich aus meiner
position oder vielleicht ich projizierte
mich ein bisschen auch in ihrer haltung
in ihrer identität in ihren lebensstil
hinein und wenn ich mir das vorstelle
dass wir nicht zu diesen direkten
krisenherden gehören hier in der schweiz
die sie besuchen besucht haben wo es
sehr viel toleranter breit offen zu und
her geht und ich keine solch eine starke
identität habe die in eine große krise
kommen kann weil meine toleranz rahmen
extrem groß ist und weit ist und sich
eigentlich vor lauter toleranz manchmal
nicht mehr weiß wo ich überhaupt stehe
das dass das ein problem sein kann für
uns hier dass wir diese dieses
intellektuelle schwanger gehen und diese
note zu diskutieren nicht haben und wir
uns deshalb zu streuen mit ich weiß ich
weiß
sex macht geld ja ja ja ja das stimmt ja
ja das dass das ist sehr interessant und
ein gewisser weise war das auch so ein
paradox dass ich erfahren habe also dass
man eigentlich philosophie und und
diskussionen besser fliegen konnte mit
menschen von dem man es eigentlich nicht
erwartet wie eben diesen rassistischen
juden oder den strenggläubigen muslim
weil die eben doch wirklich für etwas
einstehen das heißt da geht es um etwas
da ist etwas das das sind echt das sind
echte fragen und das sind werte und
überzeugungen die sie verteidigen wollen
und insofern und wann für mich diese
gespräche manchmal tatsächlich
spannender als die die ich mit meinen
studenten in montreal habe die eben auch
so sagen wir mal 70 rand manchmal zum
relativismus auch neigen und und wo man
dann irgendwie gar nicht an stößt also
da gibt es gar keine steine des anstoßes
und da haben sie recht ich denke das hat
sich vielleicht ein bisschen so
verändert nach nach nine eleven also da
nachdem nach nach also nach nachdem sich
auch die geopolitik verändert hat und
ebenso ein gefühl entstanden ist dass
wir uns gegen den religiösen
fundamentalismus gewesen gehen zum takt
das denke ich auch ja ja genau also ich
denke wir unterliegen alle tag liegt
also
das ist durchaus dass diese prägung
genau genau also dieses unreflektierte
ich habe für mich diese erfahrung mit
den ägyptischen studenten die ich
geschrieben habe das war 2000 war ich
auch nicht mehr so jung damals ende 20
und da bin ich sozusagen zum ersten mal
im eigenen takt herausgerissen worden
und musste eben für meinen atheismus für
meine säkulare weltsicht argumentieren
und habe ihm festgestellt wie wenig ich
kritisch ich über diese grundüberzeugung
eigentlich nachgedacht hat also das war
mein eigener mein eigener tag liedes
also das heißt sowohl säkulare als auch
religiöse menschen können dem
unterliegen oder auch nicht ich war also
ich habe eben auch eben auf religiöse
menschen getroffen die weniger dem takt
unterlagen als ich damals
insofern ist das glaube ich eine ein
universelles phänomen
und ja ich denke es gibt so eine gewisse
tendenz jetzt auch im westen sollten die
eu aufklärung die man dann stark macht
gegen den angeblichen religiösen
fundamentalismus also wo sich dann die
grenzen so die fronten verhärten und das
ist einerseits hat es nur positive
seiten effekte könnte man sagen denn
also die menschen stehen wieder für
etwas ein sie wollen wieder etwas
verteidigen aber wenn das dann eben
nicht in eine sagen wir mal
intellektuell produktive diskussionen
umgeleitet wird dann läuft das glaube
ich nur auf relativ nah uninteressante
konfrontationen hinaus wo man wird sagen
die eigenen plattitüden immer wieder
geholt aber dass wir auch ein
vielleicht haben ja ein bedürfnis nach
nach weisheit aufklärung in dem sie nach
nach diskussion aber wir haben durch
auch sich ein bedürfnis nach identität
und mentalität und das problem das wird
auch kurz angeschnitten ihrem buch nicht
nicht sehr vertieft dass wir einfach in
einer welt leben wo in solaris da sein
wo es eine hegemonie einer einzelnen
kultur gar nicht mehr gibt auch die
mohawk indianer in ihren reservaten
haben spielhöllen in ihrem reservat um
machen damit geld und gesund kämpfen mit
einer art von kurden teilt die
importiert ist aber kriegen sie nicht
mehr los ja genau
also genau genau also in gewisser weise
sind wir schon in dieser art
streitkultur
die ich fördern will ich will eigentlich
nur etwas verbessern was ich glaube was
schon vereint was schon da ist was
unvermeidlich in dieser globalen welt wo
wir eben ständig grenzen überschreiten
nicht wahr durch reisen durch
ökonomische verbindungen durch das
fernsehen und so weiter also das heißt
wir sind eigentlich ständig mit der
tatsache konfrontiert dass es menschen
gibt die ganz anderes denken ganz anders
leben als wir und das denke ich erzeugt
einen gewissen rechtfertigungsdruck das
heißt der tag ried ist eigentlich oft
schon zerbrochen und und mir geht es ein
gewisser weise darum werkzeuge zu
liefern mit der wir diese situation die
vielleicht zunächst mal nicht angenehm
ist produktiv machen können also etwas
daraus sozusagen dann so etwas positives
daraus ziehen können und dass das bietet
uns zum zum letzten teil und das ist
spreche ist für und quasi die lessons
learned jaja debriefing sagen was sind
die nächsten schritte
also ich habe dieses buch jetzt erstmal
abgeschlossen und ich gesagt habe
es ging es mir darauf darin durchaus
auch um sozusagen um das beispielhafte
nicht wahr so dass man das also auch als
modell benutzen kann
ich habe jetzt nicht unmittelbar vor
neuen workshops organisieren obwohl ich
immer eigentlich zu den wunsch hatte mal
in den iran zu gehen das hat nicht
geklappt ich hatte da kontakte aber dass
das hat leider nicht funktioniert denn
im iran gibt es wirklich eine sehr
lebendige philosophische kultur auch
traditionelle philosophische kultur gibt
es auf das mittelalter zurückgeht was
wiederum mit dem klischeebild ist iran
natürlich nicht übereinstimmt und und
und damit wollte ich mich gerne
auseinandersetzen und es gibt
tatsächlich im iranischen parlament
viele ausgebildete philosophen und also
wenn sich da mal eine möglichkeit bietet
das ich auch gerne mal machen würde wäre
sozusagen ich weiß ich bin eigentlich
über den mittleren osten nicht richtig
hin aus oder nahmen das habe ich auch
gedacht nicht hinausgekommen und das
hängt auch ein bisschen mit meiner
eigenen biografie zusammen und mit
meiner akademischen spezialisierung ich
kann mich da eben besser aus beherrsche
die sprachen auch
aber es würde mich durchaus reizen mal
nach china oder indien zu gehen das wäre
für mich auch nochmal was ganz neues und
da müsste ich mich noch mal eine ganz
neue denkweise einarbeitung da gibt es
natürlich auch ganz reiche tradition des
philosophierens das argumentieren die
kommen in dem buch nicht vor aber das
ist glaube ich reiner zufall
was würden sie denn gerne lernen quasi
von von asiatischen religionen und
philosophien also das konzept ist eine
wahl hat mich eigentlich wirklich immer
immer fasziniert weil es finde ich
unsere denkweise so ganz entgegen steht
nicht mal so wir wollen eigentlich immer
vollkommen denn wir wollen mehr sei es
jetzt reichtum oder wissen aber dass man
irgendwie versuchen soll sich von diesem
ganzen bestrebungen zu befreien das
finde ich also ganz eigentlich
unplausibel das ist für mich zunächst
einmal wirklich eine ganz ganz große
herausforderung
das überhaupt nachvollziehen zu können
und mich damit sozusagen intensiver zu
beschäftigen und und und und auch
verstehen zu lernen dass man eine
bestimmte idee von glück damit verbinden
kann oder von befreiung das ist dass das
finde ich sehr spannend und wenn ich
dann mal eine möglichkeit ergibt aber im
moment arbeite ich eigentlich vor allem
an einem sehr viel persönliche
persönlichen buch naht familien hmm war
und da geht es glaube ich könnte man
sagen auch um dieses gefühl der
heimatlosigkeit ich war also das gefühl
eigentlich nirgendwo so richtig dazu zu
gehören und dann durch die
rekonstruktion der eigenen
familiengeschichte so etwas wie heimat
zu schaffen das eigentlich nicht eine
heimat die sozusagen nicht an einen ort
gebunden ist sondern die sich aus der
geschichte heraus ergibt also das dann
nehme ich das projekt sozusagen und
kassen gewisser weise nach innen könnte
man könnte man sagen sind sie merken ich
am anfang ein bisschen psychologie
wieder ja ja was sie ihre eigene
biografie diese diese multi kulti
identität und das fand ich dann
interessant am schluss des buches eine
eine episode wo sie auf sich alleine
zurückgeworfen in montreal sind und
irgendwann ein
ärzte ärzte wartezimmer sitzt diese
multikulturalität kann er das auf sie
ein und man scheint zu spüren dass da
etwas wie melancholie oder tristesse auf
kommt in dieser multikulturalität wie
hat man dass diese diese schluss dieses
bild so zu lesen sowie also ich bin ja
eher schon seit 16 jahren in kanada also
ich habe da meine erste akademische
stelle bekommen und bin immer noch da
und war aber zuvor nie in nordamerika
also zum ersten mal in nordamerika hat
sich das interview hat er für die stelle
und ich bin mit dieser erwartung dahin
gekommen dass es eben dieses ganz
lebendige multikulturelle diese
multikulturelle vielfalt ist dass ich
der dort begegnen würde in montreal und
dass die menschen im gespräch sind und
sich austauschen und konflikte austragen
und so weiter und es geht dann doch eher
friedlich zu und das war vielleicht gut
aber aber auch so ein bisschen
enttäuschend also dass diese vielen
immigranten gruppen die in montreal
zusammen treffen oder auch in toronto
natürlich allgemeinen nordamerika dass
die eigentlich eben nicht in so einem
austausch befasst sind wie die dänen den
ich durch dieses projekt fördern will
und ja ich sass daneben im ärztezimmer
zwischen russischen juden und einem
ehepaar aus quebec und wurde von einem
iranischen arzt dann behandelt und so
also nicht mehr also man ist auf engstem
raum zusammen
man kann sehen wie gut es eigentlich
auch zu sagen in der zivilgesellschaft
dann funktioniert also das heißt diese
menschen die mit ganz unterschiedlichen
hintergründen und religiösen
hintergründen wir hatten so weiter
zusammen kommen die können eben gut
miteinander auskommen die sitzen da im
zimmer zusammen und kämpfen sich nicht
und der arzt behandelt sie alle gleich
und so aber das spannende gespräch
findet eben nicht statt das sollte
natürlich nicht mehr zimmer stattfinden
aber die gesellschaft hat eben diese
räume eigentlich nicht entwickelt wo man
dann auch sich austauschen kann über
diese diese diese großen
verschiedenheiten die wir alle auch
mitbringen das wird so ausgemalt und das
fand ich
da bin ich dann etwas kritisch dem
kanadischen multikulturalismus gegenüber
obwohl ich durchaus seine vorteile sehe
und den frieden genießen indem ich der
liebe fand ich dass ich ein bisschen
langweilig wäre dann vielleicht das wort
debatte debattenkultur zu sanft in dem
zusammen müsste man von streitkultur
reden ja ja doch also genau dass es geht
mir eben wirklich also eben nicht um
dieses friedliche zusammenleben es geht
mir um eine art mittelweg könnte man
sagen zwischen gewalt und oder zwischen
krieg und frieden
wenn man das so nennen will also dass
man denjenigen der anders denkt jetzt
nicht die eigene meinung aufzuzwingen
versucht oder ihnen über den haufen
schießt im schlimmsten fall aber dass
man eben auch nicht einfach alles so
stehen lässt beziehungsweise überhaupt
nicht anspricht sondern dass man
tatsächlich räume schafft wo man diese
differenzen diese
meinungsverschiedenheiten austragen
das ist ein akt ein politischer akt das
denke ich ja ganz stark also die
differenzen selbst die
meinungsverschiedenheiten selbst die
sind natürlich wichtig aber alleine
glaube ich reichen die nicht aus um an
solche streitkultur zu schaffen und also
ein mal eben durch das schulprojekt nur
dass wir schon gesprochen haben also
dass man eben den bürgern diese
werkzeuge mitte gibt in der schule aber
dann auch dass man räume schafft in der
dieser sind und besetzung stattfinden
können also dass man das erst einmal
bejaht und dann umsetzt politisch
umgesetzt
wenn wir sie jetzt als ein philosoph
seine frau auf mission schicken sagen
das geld reicht nicht bis nach china
aber bis sagen wir schweiz oder
deutschland jahr her
und weil es ein politisches projekt ist
letztlich auch und weil es um
demokratieverständnis und all diese
dinge geht auch mit welchem
philosophischen oder nicht
philosophischen politiker rührten sie
gern einen workshop ab also man hat mich
immer ein paar mal gefragt warum ich da
nicht ein workshop mit hausfrauen in new
jersey
erhalten habe und ich glaube das wäre
auch sehr spannend gewesen
bei den politikern also mein ansatz ist
könnte man sagen bottom up nicht top top
bottom das heißt ich möchte eigentlich
zu diesmal die bürger erreichen und den
politischen diskurs könnte man sagen
intelligenter machen so dass dann die
politiker einem auch nicht mehr dass
erzielen können was sie wollen also das
wirklich dann eine kritische
bürgerschaft da ist die sozusagen vor
dem vor der sich die politiker
rechtfertigen müssen ich denke so könnte
man dann die politiker dahin bekommen
dass sie selbst es heißt das pressekorps
intellekt gehen auch gerne genau in 10a
genau passiert war genau genau genau
dass man sozusagen von von unten
sozusagen sich auf arbeitet dass man
also nicht also wie plant erwartet dass
philosophen könige das ganze zum
besseren wenden sondern dass man das
versucht zu sagen von unten heraus heißt
philosophische praxis bedeutet nicht
elitär verlaufen genauso es geht also
auch um eine art im power man könnte man
eigentlich sagen der der basis genau das
ist sehr schön in den schlussworten ja
schrecklich dann geben sie dafür dass
ich bedanke mich ganz so fast
philosophische praxis will dazu anregen
gegensätze zu überbrücken und auch
nächste woche geht es um debattenkultur
es begrüßt sie hier meine kollegin
barbara bleisch mit einer neuen ausgabe
des philosophischen stammtisches
pünktlich zum anpfiff der em diskutiert
sie mit drei philosophen unter anderem
über das runde leder macht fußball
unsere welt schöner
was ist der tiefere sinn des spiels und
ist weltfußball eine ersatzreligion
diskutieren sie mit und senden sie uns
ihre fragen und kommentare an
philosophie srf punkt ch ich wünsche
ihnen einen schönen sonntag und viele
anregungen mit unserem weiteren programm
[Musik]